well margaritaville is kind of an enigma
[Music]
that's where the ship is headed
something that i never
envisioned happening when i wrote that
song in about five minutes on the seven
mile bridge it just goes to show you
that anything can happen in america
[Music]
it started with a song and when i was
just singing on
duval street in key west and i added
that song to the repertoire
right after i wrote it it immediately
got reaction
but i had no earthly idea that would
work for me as well as it has and for as
long as it has
we had started the whole thing as a lot
of people in america do as a small
business
we were t-shirt shop because we saw
people on duval street and they were
doing t-shirts with my name on them
but they spelled it wrong and i just
thought you know hell we can do better
than that
and then when john and i met it was the
fact that
i know we've got a brand here and i
don't know what to do with it i said i
can't pay you what you make up there but
you can be a partner
and you can work in bermuda shorts and
he came
[Laughter]
margaritaville was something that people
knew about
for 20 years before i joined jimmy to
build this company
they knew it not just as a song it's
really an emotion
it stands for an attitude about living
it stands for paradise it's about good
times
relaxing being with friends but it
didn't have a product
i probably owe a lot of my business
since going to nashville to try to make
it
and i realized then you had to try if
you could to
maintain control of your your
intellectual properties
and if that wasn't the case then to try
to figure out a way
to have income that wasn't attached to
like a record company contract
from which i never saw any money for
seven years
[Music]
margaritaville today really is a leisure
lifestyle platform in the world of
lodging which is our
principal business you can enjoy an
all-inclusive vacation in the caribbean
you can own or rent a resort home you
can
bring your rv or you could also rent a
cabin
if you've worked hard your whole life
and you've gotten to 55
you can do that at latitude
margaritaville when you're home in your
backyard
you can turn on our blender enjoy our
furniture around the pool and obviously
wear our clothing margaritaville
in new york as a performing musician
new york is probably the hardest market
to ever crack
as a live performer but i broke through
and
i did it with a lot of hard work and a
lot of inspiration from other people
i had to just look at it as this it's an
island and i've
i've been an island boy for a long time
it's a little different island
so i got to figure out how to get these
islanders to figure out what those other
islanders like about what i do
the nearly 370 million dollar
margaritaville times square project
is a big bet for the marketing empire
which generated around 1.5 billion
dollars in annual sales
prior to kova 19. we are bringing the
ultimate island experience to the island
of manhattan
being able to relax take a dip in a pool
have five or six different restaurant
experiences
and essentially to have a chill
environment
in the middle of one of the least chill
places in the world
it's a terrific sort of two sides of an
album if you will
so to have a margaritaville in times
square
and having had the broadway experience
this is kind of the icing on the cake to
take in new york to tell you the truth
what underlies everything we do is an
emotional connection this song has been
around
for over 40 years and it has
created significant meanings for people
in many many different ways
and often for a large number of people
it was the soundtrack to their vacations
so delivering on that expectation is
really at the end of the day
what this business is about
hey thanks for watching for more stories
like this be sure to stream bloomberg
quick take 24 7
for free at any of the places down below
get live coverage interviews
documentaries deep dives and so much
more on the stories that you
care most about and don't forget to hit
the follow or subscribe button
on twitter youtube instagram and
facebook